[Music]
it's the nicest weather the moon has
ever had
it's time to conquer and voices Rita has
a state where Group A one internet
celebrity with attitude
[Music]
what's going on here why May in the 60s
version of the Batcave Oh
Ritter's I am torn on the big weird head
I think this guy's connected needs a
little work there buddy you're coming in
Old Glory a fiddle with these knobs
[Music]
there is a great disturbance in the
force
[Music]
Vigo the scourge of Carpathia stop it
I have brought you here because Reda our
oldest and most embarrassing enemy has
returned she wishes to foil the Power
Rangers 20th anniversary what why
because she's the most pathetic villain
we've ever had and resents the shoulder
because he wants to see everything
connected to the Power Rangers destroyed
well what do you need me for I'm just a
critic comedian predict you that's
precisely why we needed Rita has taken
over every screen in the world
a feeling one of the powering just most
despised projects you don't mean yes
turbo up power rings booth
you want me to review the sequel to the
first Power Rangers film I didn't even
like the show growing up it was too old
for it
I thought it was a silly exercise and
combining Saved by the Bell with
Godzilla stock footage exert the more
you can tear the city apart the more it
will lose its power I don't know a few
Lestrange ripping into something it's
been around for 20 years
come on that's that's your credit are
you afraid you should be even the fans
don't like this movie and once they're
reminded of how stupid it all was that
remember how stupid the show was to the
Rangers this is t'rul Power Rangers
movie so yeah to start off what is it
called bad anyway I get the turbo hard
oddly enough it was the word of the week
but that's some of the epicness get lost
when you refer to it as just a Power
Rangers movie does that make it sound a
little bit more run-of-the-mill like the
writers were asking what kind of big
massive story should we tell and the
producers were like I don't care just
make a Power Rangers movie throw on a
boring long-winded Star Wars sprawl for
all I care on a distant planet lives a
great wizard named Larry go look at the
narrator is waiting for the text to come
up so he can read it golden key was
unlocks the dimensional gateways of the
universe
lerigot nothing like starting off a
movie named turbo with some slow
monotonous awkwardly paced
ex we see a planet and moldy cookie that
there's a group of soldiers chasing
after Warwick Davis this terrifying
concoction is actually a wizard named
lerigot and an evil pirate named divatox
yeah I know sounds like a blood
injection is after him because she can
use his magic to unleash an evil demon
that she wants to use to conquer the
universe but let's face it you're not
listening to a thing I'm saying right
now because you're still so focused and
how amazingly bad that puppet yeah he
always seems to have one expression
throughout the entire film
he's like the Daniel Craig of muffy do
you want but he uses his magic wand to
its EEP to earth where we see the Power
Ranger girls are spending their time
emotionally connecting and developing
children's minds at a nearby shelter and
the boys are just taking shit it turns
out they're training for a tournament a
Power Ranger rocky the other field is
simply trying too hard
hey rocky maybe they are trying too hard
maybe we're not trying hard enough bro
yourself out of a rig that's a little
tougher than it sounds guys I mean look
at this he clears right over the rope
backwards from a jump spin kick is that
even doable okay
[Applause]
so Rocky's put into a hospital as a boy
from the shelter sneaks in to say hello
but when he hears Rocky's friends coming
he hides under the bed because you do
that us he sees that they're being
called to their power ranger duties
Justin did you just hear all that you
guys are the Power Rangers they've been
to the headquarters we're up Christ
lerigot has taken great pains to hide
his exact location whoa
you know Zordon in the last movie they
at least gave you an upgrade we can make
you out better you look more
three-dimensional and your lips actually
match what you were saying why you going
back to being a half focused magic eye
picture you don't understand our entire
budget went into de patatas cleavage and
Johnny Yong Bosch his era it was a
sacrifice that needed to be made is it
really worth it look at the cleavage
prick
caviar pretty late he is somewhere in
central Africa equip yourselves with the
power boxes and teleport there
immediately under to keep a close eye
out for that westerly wear Mattel
Ghostbuster packs and go looking for
signals of soccer balls in the area a
certain snake has a taste for a certain
cat 3 what is with these guys and
throwing themselves off cliffs and she
loved it's more cautious than them
[Music]
so the Mighty Morphin powers are not
waterproof sorta hurry as long as they
never attack wisconsin dells with fall
[Music]
myself off something she injured her leg
but Tommy manages to get her to safety
meanwhile on the Ninja Turtle sub we see
that divatox has captured two on lockers
bulk and skull
you know the bullies who picked on
everybody but if they really existed
they'd be the ones that get picked on
all the time and she plans to use them
as sacrifices but the demon she's going
to bring back don't really finally I
give you one more chance
don't blow it that was silly even by the
movie standards Hitomi had finally
discovered the wizard in all his
glitching animatronic door
[Music]
my name is Tommy and this is Catherine
we're friends as the humanized version
of Disney's Tarzan welcome leap even
back to headquarters element bonds to
strangers scuba diving nearby but it
turns out they're more familiar than
they seem
it's Kimberly and Jason the original
Power Rangers team and they they
captured by divatox is videos this is
sorry you know we come back here to
surprise everybody and help out with a
shelter surprise everybody how is it
gonna surprise everybody by scuba diving
in the middle of nowhere
I mean grant and nobody was seen that
coming but I think oh wait a while
before you were discovered if ever
Rangers after all these years I have
finally located Kimberly and chase oh
yeah yeah show them on the screen oh my
god thus divatox uses them and Larry
goes wife and child to force the Rangers
to turn the wizard over I don't
understand it why does divatox want
lyrica she will likely travel to the
lost island Oh for god sakes Thomas the
Tank Engine moves his mouth more than he
does even the Zords would not be enough
to stop them so the wizard says he wants
to hand himself over but the Rangers
agreed not before they released Kimberly
in cheeks you have no choice Hillman
[Music]
era performances are near they dump the
bodies into the water only to discover
they were just dummy decoys ingenious
their acting is so lifeless nobody could
possibly tell the difference fucking
Power Rangers we're 35 minutes in and
they haven't morphed once is the reason
it's called a Power Ranger movie because
there's literally just a Power Ranger
and the entire thing well we needed that
extra time to put our new products the
turtles old well how much time do you
need to push them behold your new turbo
Zords they are extraordinary cards
vehicles equipped with the power and
velocity of turbo technology
individually they are formidable
fighting machines
when birds together they form the turbo
Megazord the most powerful Zord ever
created desert Thunder will be yours to
command
Catherine yours is called wind chaser
Tonya dues stars your turbos org and
tummy red lightning will serve you well
oh my god as marketing whores go you're
making transformers look modest it's
working your criticisms are restoring
bring themselves to the viewers and the
movies powers are getting weaker
continue your review critic all right as
time goes along we do finally see the
power rangers transform into their new
costume what do they end up doing change
immediately out of them of course I am
not even fucking kidding they dress up
in these things just so they can be out
of them in the very next scene 38
minutes in and they only change once
just to directly change out of them what
is the casual Friday
well at least make up a card right oh
you best
they drive those turbo fast morph
empowered vehicles of awesome to a 19th
century ship where they immediately get
out of their cars park them inside and
ride the incredibly uneventful HMS
pinafore since rocky is out of
commission
Zordon finds another recruit to be the
Blue Ranger you will never guess who it
fucking is the new Blue Ranger they
never had a chance
you see my folks that little pits we can
only got a few seconds of screen time is
officially the new Blue Ranger you know
we're gone no Armed Forces or military
who wants to take these jobs it's always
got to be kids and teenagers well we
knew that if any of them were crazy in
the future nobody would care it's what
all hick stars do we'll talk about this
later
right now we're gonna get those cars in
that ship oh hi skeleton to probably
question that oh well let's put this
nine-year-old in unspeakable danger by
the way do you know martial arts yeah
fucking ship ahoy but as the ship's
sails divatox manages to sneak some
monsters on board
[Music]
barely hear of a whisper I pick that up
anywhere to put the jaunty young kibosh
on these asses
[Music]
oh whoa we gotta fight this movie I was
hoping for another hour jungle searching
we're throwing ourselves off things hey
good job pretty you stop the movie
stupidity right next traps ha fuck your
traffic context
oh you think you'll have to feed me well
you haven't I call upon the power
greatest weapons you have a bully Bob a
preacher that destroys all possibilities
on the rise of franchise its latest
victim was after earth my god you still
play the movie through the airwaves
somebody has to go down there and stop
them well I'm just
it's only one alternate
it's pandering time
[Music]
[Applause]
box office poison I'm gonna give you a
review and you'll never forget I'm going
to tear apart every single one of your
contrivance 'as I'm gonna nail your
wedding the plot hole yes or no what's
the deal every time I put this helmet on
I'm jumping around like in the tension
deficit jumping bean
it is the Power Ranger always never you
guys think this movie will make any
possible sense whatsoever no your movie
is so cliche they came to put it into
words
I mean it's horrid and the rhyming it's
a joke how could anybody watch this
piece of crap and actually expect I like
it I asked you what is the point of you
keeping the Power Rangers out of the
costumes for so long do you honestly
think anyone cares about what kind of
metrosexual necklace Tommy is wearing
they don't even wear the costumes turn
the fight scene women could actually use
them and for that matter the fight team
is not even that impressive half the
monsters are defeated off screen and
even the ones who aren't look at that
they actually have to help them off the
ship that's wine and what is up with
this line is showing cell phone do you
pick anyone in your age demographic
would possibly get that was this
supposed to be a joke for adults you
know they're already on the eighth level
of Angry Birds by this point they do
that a while ago is not working sword on
he seems to be impervious to criticism
burgers whoa
will humble use head-to-head combat
right about with all of your martial
arts skills and maybe you won't have to
use the giant robot got it all right big
tall and ugly the time has come for you
which I am robot the 10 story by one
that we only use as a last resort this
guy is like a foot taller than me while
I use the giant robot first we can't why
we just fell why it's not how we do it
it's not how you do things just be
honorable what it meant about right all
right evildoer now the time has come for
me to send you into a world of go giant
robot
Wow Wow it's mega big Voltron um is
prime oh now that's the shit I'm talking
about hey you little cheater that's not
how it's done
you got a problem take it up with a
flour tortilla they used to be your
monster and just to pour more salt in
the wound I'm gonna keep reviewing the
movie think of it as a victory lap for
those who know how to use their giant
robots Oh baby up Scotty that was not
the Honorable way but what's the
effective way you can't argue with
results so Steve attacks crosses worlds
with the Wizards magic and the Rangers
bump in the meantime Kimberly escapes
with bulk and skull but Jason doesn't
get out in time why because he has to
save her from her shirt yeah
something you'll notice very quickly is
that this reappearance of the classic
Rangers is not very action-packed every
other second they have to be rescued
from divatox monsters he'll even then
with sticked met with sticks is too much
for them it would my too much if any of
the other Rangers did anything in this
movie but no it's just patiently waiting
on that goddamn boat hello there new
theme should go like this
we wait so tediously for fun please give
us something to do it's all just the
same we're boring and lame can we take
places with you but eventually they do
make it to the location of the deep
Lost Island Emir ant this but then
divatox finds out that the Rangers are
on their tail decides to call for him
hi Rita I need your advice how do I get
rid of the Power Rangers
[Music]
it's a one-minute cameo in my pajamas
and on top of that do you really want to
think about the image of me and lures ed
doing it yep oh hey Jack I flipped a
fascitis an atom to the island in his
car
wait how is that doing wait a minute
whoa oh yeah No
Dave and he finally arrives there
driving his fearsome can't this kid
catch a break first he's a frog then
that make him look like David from
Roseanne and then they give him a
minivan minivan is an emergency soccer
pickup gonna be needed in the near
future you can give it all the cool
sound effect you want it's still a mini
bear the other Rangers eventually join
him and try to save Jason whom they have
evilly dressed up as a Sith Lord and
title this divatox his perverted sense
of torture you're sick lady you're
fucking sick I mean there's big moves
and then there's dick moves in fact by
the time this walk is over I'll be
surprised if his dick moves whoa
after it looks like the natives of the
island can trick Kimberly - yeah again
though threatening men with sterics they
take them into a cave for a ceremony to
bring the demon monster to life and now
fucking finally only an hour and 10
minutes in do we finally see them
transform for fight sake and yet even a
little kid
oh wait a minute
is there a Mighty Morphin puberty burst
that happened during the transformation
can they all do that can they all growed
up over sighs I think that'd be sort of
a distinct advantage in conflict women
actually calmer if he uses this to pick
up women at bars no really babe I'm 18
now what do you say we go to my bunk bed
and I unzip my fly and never take this
costume off so they get ready to
sacrifice Kimberly and Jason to summon
the deep and I will admit this movie and
redeem itself if it partakes in a collie
style heart rebound but the Rangers show
up and they partake in their usual six
flag style stunt show
not even close but okay
but unfortunately they don't get to
Kimberly and Jason in time which means
they don't die they just get turned
Feebles which apparently in this movie
means not so strangely looking a whole
lot like that was one you named my
daughter after the Loch Ness monster
[Music]
that might be my favorite reactor in the
entire movie it either suddenly hit her
how stupid this scene is or she was
suddenly possessed by a drunk Patty and
Selma
snap into a slim jim the wizards used
their magic to snap them out of it but
nevertheless the demon is risen
causing the rangers to whip out the
weapons they went without when their
friends were in danger
that's nice monster has no interest in
joining with divatox
and instead plans to grow large and look
to cause trouble resulting in the
Rangers putting together their giant
awesome
blasters lined up in Germany
as long transformation scene taking
place while the master for the juma
blade wait
a Chilean corner results in them putting
together their biggest creation
[Music]
mega maid close enough they have a short
clash of the cretins and of course when
she know it they win the fight so how
could we possibly end after a note like
that how about the chief boxing
competition that only got two minutes of
screen time because yeah in the end
that's what it's all been building up to
right an even poorer man's version of
sidekicks
they win the tournament this key
fantasizes about this half a second for
the rest of his life and the guy who
plays rocky fires is he
[Music]
and that's turbo a Power Rangers movie
it's stupid campaign doesn't make any
sense whatsoever but what when you think
about it when everything is said and
done
gourry truth is the bolsters back
[Music]
haha now we're both gigantic and for
some reason transforms a suburban Park
into a Japanese mountainside but
nevertheless you're going
[Music]
I stopped it
you're right I can't stop it huh huh it
doesn't matter if you show how goofy or
can't be or silly it was because that's
what people liked about to begin with
it's like midgets turtles or heat man or
transformers or something like that yeah
was stupid but I still think fondly of
it because it was my childhood escape I
didn't enjoy Power Rangers but it wasn't
meant for me it was for a younger
generation of people to look back and
enjoy how preposterous Lee over the top
it was get the picture now I will
continue to show the movie to the world
tormenting everybody who watches at
dicta how the hell Mike I stopped her
from forcing everybody to watch this
movie I mean if someone who really hated
the show Quinn stop it
when rates are don't so why do they give
up the CEO powers there's nothing wrong
with them they just switched out from
Zeo to turbo so every time that Rita
throws her staff down does she just like
magic it back up every time where's her
like a big long fishing line that she
just pulls it back up really really hard
impressive evil if it turns out Lord
Zedd is actually higher up in the food
chain and how is he an emperor of evil
if there's actually a guy who is higher
up even than him Thanks all right save
the day with your ex turbed upset how
bad is the economy of Angel Grove
considering they have an abandoned
warehouse district that always seems to
be destroyed it must be a huge freaking
area well folks if something this kooky
has been around for twenty years must be
doing something right enjoy your
incredibly silly show it's ridiculous
nonsense but it's your ridiculous
nonsense I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have
Oh
[Music]
try
friends